President Vladimir Putin's unilateral
ceasefire has come into effect in
Ukraine according to Russian State
television but Ukraine's leader has
dismissed the 36-hour pause in fighting
that coincides with the Orthodox
Christmas holiday Vladimir zielinski
says Russia is attempting to stop a
Ukrainian advance in the Dom Bast region
those who continued the terror against
our country and sent all these people of
yours to be slaughtered rejecting our
proposals to stop Russian aggression
definitely do not value life and
moreover do not strive for peace they
now want to use Christmas as a cover
albeit briefly to stop the advances of
our boys in donbass and bring equipment
ammunitions and mobilize troops closer
to our positions what will that give
them only yet another increase in their
total losses and it's a bleak holiday
season for millions of ukrainians who
are struggling to get by without power
and water many are in need of food and
Medicine others are fleeing the
devastation left behind by fighting in
the Eastern regions well let's go live
to Charles Stratford who's in key for us
if I guess the big question Charles is
going to be what Ukraine does next while
Russia institutes this pause
well I think the first sort of questions
you should be asked is just how much
Russia is going to Institute this pause
um there's a huge skepticism here as we
heard from the Ukrainian president there
as to the real motivation for this
announcement for this unilateral
ceasefire
um by the Russian president uh zielinski
calling it a cover-up potentially giving
Russian forces an opportunity to move
more equipment closer to the front lines
more Personnel that was um that was
supplemented by a tweet by the Ukrainian
foreign minister Dimitra calaba last
night who said that anything like this
from President Putin offering some sort
of ceasefire should not be taken
seriously could labor drawing attention
to the fact that on Christmas Eve for
example a massive rocket strike against
the city of Kerrison in the South killed
at least 10 civilians and injured many
more and then of course we've had um
over the new year period huge barrages
of so-called Kamikaze drones and Russian
cruise missiles targeting energy
infrastructure here in Kiev and across
the country so as I say there is huge
skepticism from the get-go about this
kind of announcement from poutine it's
highly unlikely that we'll see really
any kind of change in in game plan by
the ukrainians militarily I think also
it's interesting aside from the military
perspective to draw attention to the to
the gradual move by the ukrainians away
from what they say or any kind of
perception of being in any way close to
the Russian Orthodox Church it was
2019 where the ukrainians set up a
church that they say has no affiliation
they don't want any influence from the
Moscow patriarch whatsoever and also
there seems to be a gradual movement
that is sort of escalated in in recent
years by many people in Ukraine that
don't want any association with the
Russian Orthodox church or the Julian
calendar at all and are advocating that
Christmas actually be celebrated
according to the Gregorian calendar on
the 24th and the 25th of December so
yeah whether it be militarily or if you
like with respect to when Christmas
should be celebrated there is a great
skepticism here in Ukraine and many
people saying this was just Vladimir
Putin trying to get if you like some
sort of moral High Ground
across the the Slavic certainly Slavic
speaking and the Orthodox Christian
world yeah we are of course on the eve
of Orthodox Christmas how are ukrainians
coping on that time
well you can imagine Rob yeah the
situation is is pretty bleak and most
especially close to the front lines you
know in the donbass area
um in the East and the South we're
expecting Services Orthodox Christmas
services to be held
um today and tomorrow but the
humanitarian situation across the
country as you alluded to in the intro
is desperate and the country's still
needing billions of dollars of
humanitarian Aid a month
um this escalation or slight escalation
that we saw in fighting around her son
which of course was liberated by the
ukrainians in November that shelling
that I alluded to earlier we saw a lot
of people who had moved back to kirison
since moving out again
um afraid of that shelling it's a
similar kind of scenario right the way
down through along the Eastern Front
Line where over the last 24 hours we've
heard of heavy fighting all the way from
the north towns along the Donetsk
against border like tosuke all the way
down through bakmut that Flashpoint Town
we're hearing actually reports that we
cannot verify by
um Russian telegram channels saying that
Russian forces have moved into the town
of solidar now that's north of back moot
an illustration of how intense the
fighting still is there and that
continues all the way down through the
towns like abdievka close to Russian
occupied Donetsk
um and and further south to towns like
marienka as well so yeah a very Bleak
Orthodox Christmas for for millions of
ukrainians as as the fighting continues
Charles Stratford life I think Eve
Charles thanks very much indeed